[Music]
the wait is finally over America yes
re line Dec jr. is the new bachelor it's
been a little surreal last time we saw
the 35 year old he was mending a broken
heart after making it to Emily Maynard's
final two in season 8 of The
Bachelorette back in 2012 only to be
turned down in the final moment I had
more confidence with Jef according to
former bachelor Sean Lowe Arie was
actually tapped to be the bachelor once
before so why come back now I'll be 36
in a few weeks so for me it's time so
let's get reacquainted with our new
leading man here are 5 things you may
not remember Arie has a need for speed
he's a racecar driver just like his
famous pops Arie line Dyke senior but
after his big Bachelorette letdown the
adrenaline junkies stepped out of the
spotlight to pursue a career in real
estate
he's multilingual Ari's first language
was actually Dutch Arie was born in the
Netherlands his family immigrating to
the US when he was 3
as for what we can expect from our E's
upcoming season lots of smooching
he was dubbed the kissing bandit back
when he courted em but most important of
all re knows what he wants
give a three characteristics of your
ideal woman god I would say independent
strong but then still gentle Ari's
raised to find love begins in January